et pour rendre hommage à omar qui est en
train de tourner actuellement avec
harrison ford les chroniqueurs ont fait
le sav de tpm paix et franchement vous
avez été très très bon regarde après
c'est un mets simplement de tp mais
bonjour il s'éteint suzanne ça va mon
chéri oui ça bah moi non j'ai pas
d'argent
oh ma pauvre tu aurais pas doser pour
moi ah bah non un toit des meurtres pour
100 g plus un rond ah ouais bah ouais
papa deux habitants vis après vente au
top et bonjour oui bonjour je vous
appelle parce que je trouve qu'on voit
beaucoup trop benjamin castaldi dans tpm
p ah non non non je trouve pas assez
faim tout est pas d'accord avec moi on
en conclut demain le mag est elle vit on
n'en peut plus on est à bout on est à
banon
servir le thé pembe bonjour alors tu
viens plus aux soirées et ba et ba
dommage il ya deux jours on a fait une
soirée rentrée des classes je peux te
dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de stylos et
alors eh ben je faisais la trousse faux
nom service après-vente de tpm paix
bonjour oui bonjour excusez moi vous
n'êtes pas l'autre cours de la télé ah
non je suis gilles verdez ah bah c'est
bien ce que je disais faisait trop de
coups de lattes et non mais alors quoi
ça les impressions de tb bonjour oui
bonjour ça s'appelle c'est pour savoir
si vous restez des pistes de en stop
assez franchement la charge mais bien
sûr alors nous avons le fils delon a pas
déjà fait à le fils trump déjà fait
assez ainsi on a le fils sarkozy
ah bah ouais mais déjà pas aussi bon
c'est non non non des stocks un peu une
fin de race le fils castaldi et ouais
mais déjà fait bah je suis désolé à la
meuf c'est une chaudière c'est un volcan
service après-vente des tpb bonjour
bonjour madame je vous appelle j'ai bien
compté hier soir qu'elle ait des 9 mo/s
normal ah ouais tu veux 110 de plus ta
gueule service après-vente de tpm paix
bonjour mon amour est ce que tu veux
m'épouser
oui je veux bien c'est vrai mais non
c'est faux et maman viens d'avoir verdez
au téléphone il est toujours aussi con
les atouts du maroc vos amis en famille
l'algérie